Bienvenidos a este análisis donde vamos a desgranar esa cuenta atrás que ya tenemos
encima para adaptar nuestros sitios web a la Ley 21.719.
Vamos a transformar un texto legal, que francamente es súper denso, en una hoja de ruta totalmente
práctica para diciembre de 2026.
Básicamente vamos a ver una lista de verificación de cinco puntos críticos, políticas de privacidad,
banners de cookies opt-in, formularios con casillas desmarcadas por defecto, canales
ARC-OP y, por supuesto, los contratos de datos con terceros.
Quienes gestionan plataformas digitales se enfrentan a un cambio de paradigma brutal.
Y entender esto ahora mismo es la única forma de evitar un auténtico desastre operativo.
¡Vamos a ello!
Para que esto sea súper fácil de digerir, vamos a seguir esta ruta.
Empezaremos viendo la nueva realidad digital.
Luego entraremos de lleno en las políticas de privacidad claras, pasaremos a los banners
y formularios activos y desmitificaremos los canales para derechos ARC-OP.
Después echaremos un vistazo a los contratos con terceros y terminaremos hablando de dinero,
el coste del incumplimiento.
Bueno, pues empezamos por el principio, la nueva realidad digital y lo que está verdaderamente
en juego con esta ley.
Hay que entender que esto no va de actualizar un texto aburrido escondido en el pie de página,
es algo mucho más profundo.
Fijaos bien en este número, 20.000 UTM.
Literalmente, este es el riesgo financiero máximo al que se enfrentan las empresas si
deciden mirar para otro lado.
Estamos hablando de sumas millonarias que no son un simple gasto de negocio, es un
golpe masivo que puede hundir la viabilidad de cualquier empresa.
Es el aviso definitivo de que la privacidad, amigos, ya no es una simple sugerencia.
Y es que la Ley 21.719 no es un simple lavado de cara.
Hablamos de un cambio de ingeniería total para cualquier plataforma en Chile.
¿Por qué?
Pues porque eleva los estándares al altísimo nivel europeo y, ojo a esto, crea una Agencia
de Protección de Datos Personales totalmente autónoma.
O sea, un organismo con poder real y directo para fiscalizar y poner multas.
Y aquí está el meollo del asunto.
Durante más de 20 años funcionábamos con el consentimiento tácito, es decir, tú entrabas
a una web y, por el simple hecho de navegar, se asumía que decías sí, acepto.
Pues bien, esa suposición ahora es 100% ilegal.
Hemos pasado al consentimiento explícito, ahora necesitas una prueba afirmativa, clara
y demostrable de que el usuario ha dicho que sí de forma consciente.
Vale, sé que suena abrumador, pero respirad hondo.
Toda esta complejidad legal se puede filtrar en esta lista de verificación de cinco puntos
críticos.
Primero.
Políticas de privacidad.
Segundo.
Los banners de cookies con opt-in real.
Tercero.
Nada de casillas marcadas por defecto en los formularios.
Cuarto.
Tener listos los canales ARS o P.
Y quinto.
Amarrar los contratos con terceros.
Si dominamos estos cinco pilares, transformamos un riesgo gigante en un entorno digital seguro.
Vamos al punto número uno de nuestra lista, Políticas de privacidad claras.
Se acabaron los días de copiar y pegar un texto genérico e incomprensible lleno de
jerga legal.
Esas frases de «nos importa mucho tu privacidad»…
no sirven absolutamente para nada.
La política tiene que ser transparente y declarar cuatro cosas innegociables.
Tenéis que identificar exactamente qué datos estáis pidiendo, explicar para qué los queréis
de forma específica, decir cuánto tiempo los vais a guardar y, por último, si se
los vais a pasar a un tercero, hay que decirlo alto y claro.
Ya no hay base legal para guardar correos o teléfonos por si acaso en un futuro nos
hacen falta.
Avanzamos a los puntos dos y tres.
Banners y formularios activos.
Aquí es donde el diseño de vuestra web choca de frente con la ley.
Si alguna vez os habéis preguntado si esas típicas casillas de «acepto recibir ofertas»
que ya vienen marcadas por defecto siguen siendo legales, la respuesta es un NO rotundo.
Cualquier formulario de contacto o página de pago tiene que requerir un clic activo
y voluntario del usuario.
La inacción o el silencio ya no son un sí.
El consentimiento ahora tiene que cumplir estas cuatro reglas de oro.
Tiene que ser libre, o sea, sin obligar a nadie.
Informado.
Súper específico.
Nada de agrupar mil cosas en un solo botón.
E inequívoco.
Esto hace que esos muros de «acepta todo para poder seguir leyendo» sean historia.
Y un detalle técnico que es fascinante.
Si alguien pudo aceptar con un solo clic, la ley dice que tiene que poder cancelar ese
consentimiento igual de rápido, con un solo clic.
Esto va a obligar a rediseñar muchísimas plataformas.
Pasamos al cuarto punto.
Canales para derechos ARSOP.
Y esto requiere cambios estructurales importantes en la sala de máquinas de cualquier web.
ARSOP no es una palabra inventada.
Son las siglas de cinco derechos fundamentales.
Acceso, para que el usuario sepa qué datos tenéis.
Rectificación, para corregirlos si están mal.
Supresión, para borrarlos.
Oposición, para deciros «oye, no uses mis datos para marketing».
Y portabilidad, que es entregarles sus datos en un formato estructurado para que se los
lleve a otra parte.
Hay que tener canales digitales clarísimos y accesibles para que la gente pueda ejercer
cualquiera de estas cinco acciones.
Y ojo con esto, porque aquí viene la urgencia técnica real.
Tenéis un plazo de dos días hábiles para ejecutar un bloqueo temporal de datos.
Dos días.
Treinta días como plazo estándar para responder a una solicitud normal.
Y un máximo de sesenta días para temas muy complejos.
Recibir una petición y tener que bloquearla en cuarenta y ocho horas exige un nivel de
automatización que, seamos sinceros, la mayoría de los sistemas actuales no tienen
ni de broma.
Llegamos al quinto y último punto de la lista.
Contratos con terceros.
Porque hoy en día nadie opera en una burbuja aislada.
Aquí entran los encargados de tratamiento.
Hablamos de vuestro servidor en la nube, el CRM, la herramienta de analítica web, cualquier
integración externa.
Para que toque datos de vuestros usuarios, necesita un acuerdo formal, por escrito, que
garantice que ese proveedor también cumple la ley.
Porque si vuestro proveedor falla, la responsabilidad legal sigue siendo vuestra, no podéis delegar
la culpa.
Y para terminar, hablemos de lo que pasa si ignoramos todo esto.
El coste del incumplimiento.
La época en la que estas normas eran simples recomendaciones teóricas se ha acabado.
El nuevo sistema clasifica las infracciones en tres niveles que asustan.
Leves hasta 5.000 UTM, graves hasta 10.000 UTM y las gravísimas hasta 20.000 UTM.
Ignorar a un usuario que pide borrar sus datos o tener un banner engañoso es motivo de sanción.
Pero lo más fuerte de todo es que cualquier persona, desde el sofá de su casa y a golpe
de clic, puede denunciar una web ante la agencia de forma totalmente gratuita.
El riesgo de que os hagan una auditoría se multiplica por mil.
Así que todo esto nos deja con una pregunta final inevitable.
¿Vuestras plataformas digitales actuales van a ser un motor de crecimiento en el que
la gente confíe, o se van a convertir en una bomba de relojería de 20.000 UTM para
diciembre de 2026?
El reloj ya está en marcha.
La privacidad por diseño es una exigencia operativa ineludible hoy mismo.
El momento exacto para hacer esta auditoría y empezar la transformación de vuestros sistemas
es ahora, mucho antes de que la cuenta atrás llegue a cero.